ils ne l'ont pas bien accueilli les
soignants cette note de la direction
générale de la santé il s'agit d'un
document de quatre pages adressée à tous
les professionnels du secteur les
autorités y détaille les leviers
d'action pour continuer à faire tourner
les hôpitaux pendant l'hiver notamment
les services d'urgence et en résumé ce
que dit cette note est bien c'est que
les soignons pourront être
réquisitionnés pour faire face à
l'afflux de patients le texte évoque
même une mobilisation possible des
professionnels retraités certains
personnels hospitaliers craignent ainsi
de devoir passer les fêtes de noël à
l'hôpital alors que beaucoup d'entre eux
sont harassés par deux années de
pandémie ça va être une catastrophe
parce que les médecins qui sont encore à
l'hôpital eux ils restent déjà tout en
serrant les dents quand ils vont
apprendre qu'en plus ils vont être
réquisitionnés pour aller aux urgences
mais au secours la réquisition un
certain nombre de personnels risque de
s'y soustraire en disparaissant de la
circulation ça fait deux ans qu'on a été
obligé de reporter d'annuler nos
vacances personnellement j'ai un an sur
mon compte épargne temps je vais les
prendre quand d'autant que le coc vide
n'est pas le seul responsable les
professionnels de santé alertent depuis
longtemps sur le manque chronique de
personnel le système hospitalier
français connaître est même une
hémorragie des personnels médicaux ou
paramédicaux selon certains or réduction
programmée au début de l'automne 6 % des
lits étaient fermés selon la fédération
hospitalière de france dans la majeure
partie des cas du fait d'un manque
d'infirmières ou de praticiens environ
13 % de nos lits étaient fermés début
novembre contre 10 9% fin septembre nous
avons 1200 postes d'infirmières non
pourvus sans compter les infirmières
spécialisées les manipulateurs radio et
d'autres
les tensions sont très fortes notamment
sur le personnel de nuit qui représente
entre 35 et 40% des postes vacants le
patron de l'ap-hp a par ailleurs déclaré
ce lundi que les conséquences de la
cinquième vague sur l'hôpital ne sont
pas attendus avant fin décembre début
janvier si elle devait se produire et
oui parce que grâce à l'immunité chaque
jour plus répandue dans l'hexagone on
peut raisonnablement espérer que les
personnes contaminées seront moins
nombreuses à développer une forme grave
de la maladie qu au cours des vagues
précédentes le coc vide pourrait donc
peser moins fort sur le système
hospitalier qu'il ya un an la note de la
dgs rappelle d'ailleurs je cite que les
difficultés à remplir les tableaux de
gardois maintenir une offre de soins
complète sont récurrentes depuis
plusieurs années pendant les mois
d'hiver et d'été et il faut se rappeler
que les professionnels de santé
manifestait déjà avant la crise du coc
vide pour plus d'embauchés à l'hôpital
si les soignants devront passer noël au
travail ce ne sera donc pas uniquement
en raison du coc vide mais bien aussi à
cause des politiques de santé menées ces